hi everyone just a big thank you for
watching all those amazing videos I hope
you had as much fun as I did making them
now just a quick reminder to subscribe
to the YouTube channel to get the latest
and updated and the most exciting videos
I've ever done just press click to
subscribe
best wishes enjoy and many thanks first
off get your ocean tray put the tray on
the gas port ribs
60% meat and 35 40 % fat
given the really good seasons salt and
pepper nice thing about this cut they
stay incredibly moist when they're on
the bone and the longer you cook them
the more delicious they become just push
all that seasoning in to the pork pull
of all in make sure that trey is nice
and hot and I really want that nice sort
of camera zation taking place on the
pork that's the nice thing about
starting it on top of the stove use your
ocean freight get them colors and then
the of them putting the ribs straight in
the oven you don't get the color it
looks sort of oils as opposed to a nice
caramelized with ginger you can't beat
fresh ginger with sticky pork ribs place
it down nice and firmly and slice thinly
slice the ginger the more fragrant the
ribs garlic
I was really important before you add
anything those ribs make sure we've got
the color in the ribs first and rush it
turn them over that's what I want a nice
crispy color a very sort of braised in
the oven all that color just turns into
the most amazing flavor braising is just
a chef's turn for cooking something
slowly in liquid fights ginger and
garlic in spread it around on all those
ribs to sort of roast the ginger and the
garlic chili flakes chili flakes in next
Szechuan pepper citrusy vibrant
peppercorns incredible in next star anis
that gives it a really nice sort of
aniseed flavor almost like you're
roasting the ribs in fennel then now
we've got the heat got the spice on
sweeten things up a little bit some
fresh honey honey glazes the poor
beautifully counteracts against all that
spice in there well look what's
happening color on the ribs is
extraordinary it's like a really nice
chili sweet caramel now soy sauce brings
that little bit of sort of saltiness to
it really generous with a soy sauce
Japanese vinegar 2 tablespoons of
vinegar in rice wine it gives it that
nice sort of tartness the ribs if you
can't find rice wine a dry sherry is a
great substitute
300 mil that takes out the heat for that
Szechuan pepper those dry chili flakes
make sure they all lay down like a nice
tight box of matches bring that up to
the boil cooking is all about learning
to develop your own likes and dislikes
so always keep tasting to make sure
you're happy with a combination of
flavors it's lacking a little touch of
vinegar without sharpness now think
what's going on the tartness the heat
the caramel the color on the ribs is
amazing I want a bit of a sort of oniony
flavor this is spring music whilst these
ribs are in the oven the spring onions
all sort of puree we give a sharpness to
the final taste of that pork in the my
spring onions in my stock 400 mil of
stock this is just a simple chicken
stock the stock just sits underneath the
ribs it absorbs into the rib and the top
of the rib glazes underneath the rib
that gets crispy and rich and that's
what makes the ribs nice and moist
really important into the oven mmm
cook at 180 for 30 minutes then turn the
ribs over and cook for a further 30
minutes now Wow
they smell incredible each side has got
a really nice crispy roasted edge
becomes sticky and chewy and sweet sour
the fats disappeared and the pork just
melts in your mouth I want to take them
to the next level gasps back on now
shake the tray and this is the sort of
the way that we finish them in the
restaurant but every minute they'd lay
zs-- in that tray they just get to taste
better and better now look at them
I'm so happy with us ribs done
absolutely delicious now but if you want
you can put them in the fridge
and a flavor will keep developing then
just reheat them when you want to serve
so each group has a nice slice of ginger
on there Wow look at that delicious
sticky ribs with an amazing marinade
season uncover well with paprika spread
evenly usual pierce the open squeeze it
in that delicious